souchet bonjourbonjour derrière nous une
petite manifestation que vous que vous m
suivant doit ça vous rappelle quand même
des souvenirs vous avez été en charge de
tout ça il ya deux ans qu'est ce qu'on a
appris à la police de montréal
c'était en fait il ya trois ans déjà en
2012 si on a connu une année très
exceptionnel en terme de manifestations
avec le conflit aps les étudiants le
conflit social
on a vécu une année exceptionnelle quant
au nombre de manifestations conduit
quant à l'intensité des manifestations
qu'on nous on a vécu plusieurs
manifestations par jour souvent de jour
de soir de nuit et c'était un après
l'eau puisque ça nous a permis de faire
dans le contexte de ces manifestations
le qui étaient des hordes dans un était
dans une proportion très très grave
c'est qu'à chaque jour ça nous demandait
de nous poser des questions il n'y a pas
de journée ou que je passerai pas avec
mon équipe sur le terrain afin que
chaque journée ce qu'on a fait la bonne
chose parce qu'on ait fait toutes les
bonnes choses et ce qu'on peut
s'améliorer ce que des choses qu'on
devrait vite et a donc on se remette en
question constamment
donc on a appris de ces événements là
comment avec l'évolution des
manifestations passées
les manifestations aussi évolué comment
on pouvait s'adapter à ce pour une seule
et unique raison on a toujours reconnu
le droit de manifester le spvm a
toujours reconnu droit de manifester et
notre rôle à travers ça c'est d'assurer
la sécurité non seulement des
manifestants mais des citoyens des
commerçants et surtout nos pas et si
c'était à refaire un élément que vous
feriez différemment vous ce serait
lequel
vous savez quoi je pense que je referais
je craignais de de vraiment le soir sont
différentes
parce que quand je regarde la façon dont
le fait est l'adaptation qu'on a pu
faire au jour le jour parmi un événement
encore une fois une année exceptionnelle
on a regardé ailleurs ça s'est passé là
et vous savez quoi dans la gestion
manifestations qu'on prenne une décision
ou une autre on fera jamais 100% de gens
heureux
donc vous dites malgré tout pied il ya
eu des critiques on le sait malgré
toutes les critiques vous vous êtes fier
du travail qui a été fait par la police
de montréal lors de ses grandes mains et
je vous trouve qu'on ne peut pas
améliorer des choses qu'il fallait
améliorer
il ya des processus serait pas
d'arrestation ou de ou de traitement des
situations on améliorer des choses là
mais dans la façon générale de gérer les
manifestations
je pense que l'espé est mort très bien
fait l'autre grande ou aussi vous aurez
à gérer si cette menace terroriste avec
les attentats de saint jean sur
richelieu avec ceux de ternois c'est
devenu beaucoup plus réelle pour lui
mourir pour les canadiens est-ce que
vous avez assez de pouvoir actuellement
pour agir dans les cégeps dans les
écoles un peu partout avez vous assez
pouvoir oui moi faites vous savez que le
phénomène n'est pas nouveau un même
avant 2001 il ya des choses qui se sont
passées
mais depuis 2001 ce qu'on a fait au
québec on a créé une structure de
gestion policière contre le terrorisme
donc on travaille le spvm avec la sûreté
du québec et la grc pour qu'ensemble on
puisse suivre l'évolution de ce
phénomène là et de tenter de le prévenir
ici malheureusement salariés d'être en
mesure d'être le plus près possible à
répondre à sa deuxième des choses qu'on
a faites dernièrement vous savez que on
parle beaucoup de radicalisation
présentement et le phénomène l'état
islamique la radicalisation on est
ouverts récemment levé de montréal a
ouvert un centre de prévention de
radicalisation menant
via la fonction oui avec le conseil que
le gouvernement du québec ce qui est le
fun de cette approche là c'est que la
radicalisation souvent les gens qui
peuvent mieux la détecter si pas
nécessairement les policiers c'est
souvent les gens qui sont dans
l'entourage des gens qui sont concernés
tickets plus le fun avec le centre de
prévention c'est que déjà peuvent faire
appel non pas un service de police puis
des fonds pense que ça peut mener à des
accusations l'emprisonnement des gens
qu'on aime c'est qu'ils vont chercher de
l'aide ailleurs au centre de prévention
et de la relation die des plus faciles
ceci dit c'est que si jamais il ya des
éléments que le centre de prévention et
à sa connaissance
quelqu'un appelle à la ligne d'urgence
examen ces cas se met en danger la
sécurité des gens ils se font un devoir
de nous appeler qu'on puisse traiter le
corps on a beaucoup parlé je regarde en
bas parce que je regardais les pantalons
on a beaucoup parlé
vous êtes arrivé en poste l'atlantide un
même pas votre cérémonie première
première prise diront plusieurs et là ça
continue ce moyen de pression
est-ce que clairement vous demander à
québec une loi pour obliger vous
policier a porté l'uniforme complet
quand j'ai rencontré les troupes sur le
terrain depuis un mois j'étais à ce
moment-la depuis un peu plus qu'un mort
j'ai eu la chance d'échanger plus de
mails envoyés pour moi là et je parle
beaucoup de fierté que mais pas ici pour
moi je parle d'une forme est vraiment
important moi lorsque l'idée alors on
commence à porter tout le monde les
pantalons régulier d'une forme demain
matin
ceci dit vous savez que d'un dans
l'historique qu'on a c'est que c'est un
moyen de pression qu'on est déjà amené
devant des instances et qui a été
reconnu comme légale au moment où on se
parle moi je pense que c'est pour moi le
plus important de parler de fierté c'est
ce que je fais avec mes policiers on a
discuté beaucoup de ce soit je comprends
mais est malgré tout le contexte pour
faciliter loi 15 négociations de
conventions collectives et et tout ça je
pense que des policiers donnent encore
et je suis convaincu que je veux
rassurer les citoyens par rapport à ce
que les politiques continuent à donner
un service de très bonne qualité mais
souhaitez vous monsieur directeur une
loi pour obliger vos policiers mais un
vrai
que ce soit de la façon dont ça va
arriver je souhaite le retour au port
régulier de l'uniforme c'est mon plus
grand souhait n'avait pas le pouvoir
d'imposer vous ça prend une loi ce que
je tenterai de vous dire c'est que dans
le passé il ya déjà des choses qu'on a
tenté qui auront pas fonctionné
présentement ce qui est certain c'est
que c'est un moyen de pression là est
tolérée par les instances qu en ont
décidé ainsi
vous avez à faire plus avec moins en
tout cas faire autant avec moins vous
avez moins de policiers ont depuis
quelques temps on se pose là quelque
chose que vraiment le besoin de
policiers pays en surtemps pour faire la
circulation à des intersections c'est
que beaucoup de travaux à mon rien c'est
ce que vous allez leur garde et vite en
disant petit on peut donner ça à
d'autres gens nous on a assez de travail
à faire mais au delà de faire plus avec
moins je mieux parler d' optimisation de
l'utilisation des ressources pour
m'assurer que 100 % de mes ressources
sont utilisées à 100%
vous parlez de chantier gestion de la
circulation tout ça c'est une fête
dimanche c'est oui c'est fait beaucoup
de monde je fais des déplacements je me
déplace puis dernièrement la semaine
passée je passe à l'intersection où ce
qu'un policiers faisaient la circulation
pour moi cet endroit là ça prenait un
policier la même chose à une autre étape
section que j'ai vu je suis pas certain
que ça prenne un policy donc dans
l'optique de d'optimiser l'utilisation
des ressources est certain que c'est des
choses que je vais regarder une petite
question à rafale pour compte une bonne
idée une caméra et les uniformes
c'est un projet pilote pour moi moi je
pense que c'est une bonne idée ou un
projet pilote et même les policiers
veulent de tout ça va donner une chance
de donner l'autre côté de la médaille
pas souvent ce qu'on sera encore pire
aujourd'hui en 2015 les c'est très
fréquent de filmer les interventions
policières ce qui n'était pas le cas
quand je rentre en 91 et mais souvent ce
qu'on voit à l'aube ou de tous les
petits bouts de vidéo mais que les
policiers portent une caméra corporelle
je pense que c'est une bonne chose ça va
venir
quels contextes d'intervention plus de
policiers venant des communautés
culturelles aussi plus de femmes est-ce
que vous c'est quelque chose d'un souci
un objectif que vous avez a toujours été
un objectif pour le service depuis
longtemps nos programmes d'accès à
l'égalité qui est encore en place
maintenant je savais que présentement
vieux plus de 50% de la population de
montréal qui et de quoi
la minorité c'est sûr que de façon
optimale on aimerait que le service de
paddy soit pas présenté de ces faits de
ce chiffre est ce que c'est encore le
coq la majorité des policiers je pense
que la majorité mais une bonne partie
des policiers habitent à l'extérieur du
territoire où vous travaillez vous par
exemple y habiter ou vous policiers ce
qu'ils habitent à mon rien je sais pas
une panne et que j'ai je vous réponds
pour moi oui j'habite à montréal je
viens de montréal j'avais à montréal en
mai pour vous il n'y a pas rien
présentement qui oblige les policiers à
la morale mais effectivement une bonne
idée de vivre dans sa communauté aussi
écouter on peut parler de son nom tant
ce qui est pas mal plus important c'est
quand on travaille dans notre communauté
c'est de la comprendre et de s'impliquer
auprès de cette communauté
l'autre derrière c'est tranquille c'est
une petite de rien ce pourvoi oui mais
il faut demeurer vigilant pareil sachez
une chose qu'on nous le centre de
commandement un traitement de
l'information
c'est qu'on possède des éléments qui
font qu'on veut la suivre à un niveau
avec un peu plus de recul que ses
adhérents
merci beaucoup merci